[Music]
we're talking with grace in phoenix her
husband lost his 60 000
job which is the best thing ever
happened to him because he proceeded to
go and make a half a million dollars in
the
coming 12 months so it turns out
whatever he's doing covett has been good
to him
and uh we'll take it congratulations
well done
so i'm gonna guess and say you guys have
lot o itis like you just hit the lotto
a little bit but we've been living below
our means for so long
and trained ourselves for so long that
it's
nothing really has changed except for
when i
log into my bank account i'm like oh
look at that so you're still living on
sixty thousand
uh yeah roughly okay
good then i was wrong i like that good
so are you
did you pay off all your debts okay
so this is bringing me to my question
what we have left
is my student loans for my nursing
degree
i have forty thousand dollars okay uh
that's the only thing that we have not
paid off
how much is in the checking account
000. you told me that earlier yeah okay
so why haven't you paid off the student
loan
because so it took me quite a few years
to get my husband on this train
do you like your student loan
i don't need to be on a train this is
this is ridiculous you have 293 000
48 000 and you're debt free tape this is
not just just instantaneous
why would you not do this does he does
he like yours does he like your student
loan
it's like now that the mortgage paying
off is within his reach he's like let's
just do that
out of order oh and then we'll go back
and pay it off
okay now that's at least a little bit
logical okay
okay so how much is how much is owed on
the mortgage stop how much your note on
the mortgage
what 320 000 okay and so how much is he
making a month right now
still making 50 grand a month
um some months it's a lot of it is his
incentive
and it's however much he works but it's
slowing down
so like last month it was like 15 000
wasn't
his incentive so it's starting to slow
down now that they're getting caught up
at his work um so it might be a few
two or three months i'm thinking until
we have the mortgage paid off
let's establish this september
easily the mortgage and the student loan
are both gone can we all agree on that
including your husband
yes okay so the only question is the
order between now
and september is this the big question
right should i just let it go and let
him have that win
since he's been doing so good it's not
going to do with him being good
pay off the student loan pay a bunch on
the mortgage
and then finish the mortgage off by
september
okay it's september
i've never seen him gazelle intense
before so i didn't want to stop him
it's not 2026 it's september and in
february of this year
this wasn't even on the table this
didn't exist that y'all would pay off
your 300 plus thousand dollar mortgage
right
right no it's not even in the realm
right
so don't get carried away y'all are so
close man congratulations
don't do this in the wrong order but
here's what you do need to do okay that
if i
if i woke up in your shoes if i came to
your home tonight we got got out some
coffee in a yellow pad and the three of
us sat there and talked
i would have you write a check while i
was sitting there and pay off the
student loan i would have you write
another
check down to a fully funded emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
and put the rest of that on that
mortgage right now tonight
and then that's going to leave you 50 60
000 bucks or whatever it is on this
mortgage
80 000 bucks on this mortgage and you're
going to just
every month you're going to chunk on
that remaining 80 grand until it's gone
and it's going to be gone before
september likely but by september for
sure
okay but i i wouldn't leave that money
sitting in that checking account
that's how boats just find their way
into your backyard
and new tahoes find their way into your
garage and all that kind of stuff that's
exactly what happened it was my birthday
a couple days ago when he went and
bought a can-am well it's only on order
at this point
he can still cancel it which i i'm like
thank you so much for the 30 000
gift but we're so close to paying off
our mortgage
you bought a 30 000 side by side not me
i know i know it was a surprise
yeah yeah that's not a good plan okay
i i listen i get it man i actually just
bought a side by side a few weeks ago
they're absolutely fabulous i've got one
on my farm i'm having so much fun with
the thing
i want you to get one of those after the
house gets paid off
okay and it may or may not be 30 000
when you do it good god is this thing
gold-plated
there i actually did buy that brand but
yeah it's
um and it's a wonderful vehicle but now
you don't do that you don't
do that well you have an emer you don't
have an emergency fund you don't
yeah and you won the lottery it is a
little bit of lotto itis
it is the can-am is a little bit a lot
of itis and the money sitting in the
checking account
and just kind of feeling like i'm rich
yeah because i haven't really i haven't
really written the checks for the stuff
i know that growing up pay it off i'm
not going to
grown-ups need to do this but i haven't
really written those checks yet so i
kind of feel like i'm rich and
you're really not because you've got all
this debt that's more than the amount in
your checking account but you kind of
feel that way that's kind of a lotto
item that's right
that's kind of like uh and one of the
things that it's uh
wealth gained quickly
is dangerous absolutely that with music
people with
athletes we see this
with uh well somebody whose income just
shoots up for whatever reason
i would go as far as say it's anything
that you get
quickly has as if you get leadership all
of a sudden gets dropped in
something something big a value yeah
something big and you don't
incrementally
gain it it has um you have more of a
tendency to
kind of be in awe of it a little bit and
um it's like uh you know like a
lady was interviewing me for a stupid
article that i shouldn't have done a
while back and she's like
did you ever think you were going to get
here i'm like
yeah i had no idea how much work it was
going to be
right that's right you know 30 years
later i'm an overnight success
right but uh what i didn't know is how
much work is gonna be but did i know
there's a bunch of people in debt that i
could sell a book on how to get out of
debt to
yeah i mean me and jenny craig got a big
job in america there's a lot of market
here
so we're gonna you know did i ever think
of course i thought
but i had no idea how much work it's
going to be and so i never wake up and
go
wow how did that happen like it was all
surprised because it was so gradual
right and so incremental over a 30 year
period of time i mean i walked through
this building and i'm like
good lord this really happened right i
mean you have those moments but then i
also kind of
yeah i know exactly how it happened
right you know it was god's blessings
and our hard work
and along the way you gather wisdom you
gather people that walk alongside you
say hey man don't do that i made that
mistake
do this right don't trip over that
that's a tripwire right there don't do
that yeah don't step in that you're
gonna it's gonna
that thing's gonna bite you don't do
that yeah so grace
you you guys have had a wonderful year
do not
let the two-year-older version of you
hate the
the 2020 version of you because you
misbehaved with this and the can-am is
straight-up misbehavior
because it's symptomatic of what's going
on if you told me you could pay off your
house
and you could pay off have your
emergency fund in place and you could
pay off the student loans
and buy the can-am i would tell you to
buy the county
the in and of itself the purchase of the
item is not a bad thing
it's the place in the order that you're
doing it
what it what that's saying about yours
hearts
your husband's in particular in this
situation he's having a whoo-hoo
moment but he could also be having this
dave he could also be having
i've never been able to provide for her
like i wanted to yeah
you know he could have done whatever all
those things are things still [ __ ] it's
not a
he's not being selfish right he might be
but he may be
yeah maybe maybe he really wanted to
count him but yeah
that's right the little boy that bought
his grandmother a tonka truck for
christmas
great guy right yeah that but i've been
that guy hey honey look what i just
bought
you yeah but the uh uh
but uh uh don't i think he just was well
who uh yeah
i think he's just my god it's been
awesome i'm just gonna buy some crap
finally
yeah and i don't think about it because
i got that money yeah but
you don't really not once you've done
smart stuff to it there's none left
that's right
so then later on you can buy the cannon
live like no one else
so later you can live and give like no
one else no discipline seems pleasant at
the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness